and then what was the time frame for the
actual filming of cyber seniors how long
did it take we shot over a period of 10
months and the editing took about a year
so it was a two-year project altogether
and you edited the film yes okay so what
did you learn about this older
generation versus the newer generation I
mean like what what parallels did you
see I'm sure probably the need to
connect but then also what were some of
the things that were complete opposite
that you saw I think it just really
opened my eyes the idea that you know
life isn't over once you reach that age
these people are still totally active
totally with it and they're having a lot
of fun retirement age actually seems
like fun to me now because they have a
free time to kind of do things that
they've always wanted to do so it's a
really good time in your life to be able
to you know take on your skills like
learning how to use the computer and I
think people that do continue learning
and taking our new skills are the ones
that really thrive later in life I'm
wondering what it is that makes us
resist technology as we get older
because I'm right now all of us oh the
internet seems fine we're used we've
kind of grown up around it but I'm sure
there'll be things in 20 years that will
seem entirely scary whether it's a
matrix-like device or you know plug in
and you get certain feelings and oh my
gosh you know we can't do this but what
do you think it is in us that makes us
resist technology as we get older well
with the seniors featured in our film
they're in their 80s and 90s so they
were out of the workforce once computers
became mainstream so they never really
had to learn how to use the internet as
a necessity for school or work so it's
completely new to them and I think that
that's really scary I think when you
have a basis for computer knowledge
you're able to pick up new technology
easier but still I mean people that are
five years younger than me are so much
faster on the internet than I am and
they know things are apps or different
technological things that I can't grasp
myself and I think you can get kind of
lazy it's kind of like no this is my
routine I'm not gonna learn anything new
but I think it's good to challenge
yourself and keep learning new things
and keep up-to-date on
nology because it is easy to fall behind
what are some of the things that seem
new to you with the internet like
different apps or you know what like
what um well every time I new app comes
out like there was snapchat now I'm
really into snapchat but my sisters are
on snapchat for like a year it was
before I even knew about it once I got
on snapchat it was like yeah that's old
news we've been using that for a year my
mom is just now getting on Instagram and
snapchat so you know it's like she takes
to it a little bit slower and then once
my mom's on Instagram it's like okay now
I need to tone down some of the photos
that I mostly older generation kind of
comes in
you